باننا
في مدريد
مع مجموعه من الدول بصوره مستمره من من
اجل تقديم
وحضور مستمر من اجل مؤازره اوكرانيا الامر
الاخير الذي لا بد لي من الاشاره اليه هو
ان جزء من غزو روسيا كان
يعتمد على ما قلته في اكثر من المناسبه
بانه اذا ما قامت
روسيا بغزو اوكرانيا فاننا سوف نقدم كل
الدعم وسوف يكون لنا حضور هنا
وسوف نفي بتعهداتنا في الفتره المقبله لذا
فاننا ملتزمون في
ما قلناه ويمكنكم ان ترهنوا على هذا الامر
هل ترغبون باضافه اي شيء
اذا لدينا فرصه لترحي سؤال اخر
معدات الى اوكرانيا لكن جزءا كبيرا منها
لم يصل حتى الان
وكان الامير عمل النيتو قد تذكر قد ذكر
بان العمليه الهجوميه قد توشك على
الانطلاق متى تعتقدون ان هذه المعدات
العسكريه سوف تصل الى اوكرانيا
متى سوف يكون لها ان تشكل فارقا وخاصه اذا
لم يتم وقف روسيا في هذه السنه وقد تكون
دول اوروبيه هي بعد ذلك
كما تعلمون روسيا قد بدات هذه العمليه
الهجوميه وكما اسلفنا القول
ان روسيا ما تزال مستمره في
تجنيد اعداد كبيره من قواتها وهذه القوات
تفتقر الى التدريب الصحيح وتفتقر الى
القدرات القتاليه
هذه المعركه
ونرى ان منطقه المخموسيه منطقه متنازع
عليها ونعتقد ان الامر سوف يكون على هذا
الحال لفتره من الزمن فيما يخص اذا ما كان
لنا القدره على ادخال هذه المعدات
العسكريه الى اوكرانيا هي مساله نعمل
عليها بصوره يوميه هذه المعدات التي تدخل
الى ميدان المعركه سوف يتم التدريب القوات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه عليها وبالمناسبه يتم
تدريب هذه القوات في اماكن متعدده
فمثلا السويت قد قدمت
وهي عباره عن
حامله جنود
والمانيا ايضا قدمت تدريبا للقوات على
استخدام
على استخدام معدات عسكريه وعلى قدره
المناوره
ومركبات برادلي وبعض الاسلحه الهجوميه
ايضا يتم التدريب القوات الاوكرانيه عليها
في المانيا
وقدره المناوره في استخدام القوه الناريه
جمله من الاشياء تاتي في نطاق واحد
ولدينا خطه تفصيليه حول كيفيه دفع الامور
التي تصبر في دعم اوكرانيا هذا هو عمل قيد
التطور لكنها مساله